the u.s navy has opted to shut down fuel
tanks and fuel lines at the pearl harbor
naval base blamed for dangerous levels
of petroleum that are contaminating not
one but now two groundwater sources
state health officials are saying
tainted water has already forced
hundreds from their homes lilia luciano
met a woman on base who is worried for
her family's health and safety
we just don't even turn on anything
military wife and mom cindy rivera fears
her family had been drinking toxic water
tainted with jet fuel for a long time
the first indication was my husband had
a rash on his face that was really
really
like violently red
she and her kids also got sick and when
the water started smelling like gas she
said no more and stopped drinking it how
much exposure do you fear that you had
like 11 days even contamination in
months before that she says it feels
like camping with her four kids at home
having to wash dishes bathe and cook
with bottled water i just think we were
living in paradise and unknowingly
having this situation where we were
getting ourselves and our kids sick i'm
disgusted really at town hall meetings
military officials have tried to
reassure anxious families but provide
little information and the issue has now
affected a second navy well we are
working day and night to figure out what
the source of
the odors ernest lau manager and chief
engineer of the honolulu board of water
supply says the navy needs to empty out
the fuel tanks and pipelines altogether
we believe that safe drinking water is
also important for our defense and for
our security lao believes the problem is
in the way the tanks were designed and
hastily built the only thing that keeps
the fuel from leaking out into the
environment and eventually into the
groundwater is a quarter inch steel
plate
that was installed and welded in place
78 years ago some military families fear
the long-term impacts to their
livelihoods and health we should do
everything we can to support these
families and show that you know this
service of our servicemen and our
families that serve alongside is not in
vain for cbs mornings i'm lilia luciano
on the island of oahu hawaii
clean water should be something we all
have access to